the next day I'm back at the port in
Kaohsiung
I want to know where all these spins are
coming from
I'm in luck there's a boat unloading and
just behind the key I find what I'm
looking for these are all sharks these
are all sharks
that's a hammerhead in Taiwan it's still
legal for fishermen to cut the fins off
sharks at sea as long as the bodies are
also brought back to port that blue
shark where the where are the fins where
are they you know where the fins care
yeah yeah
where
over there
these two bags are crammed full of fins
but it looks to me like there are loads
more fins here than bodies I can't be
sure that this is evidence of Finan but
before I get a chance to check if anyone
is monitoring this I'm confronted by
port security
I understand listen is it excuse me you
speak English no way to speak English
okay
there's loads of Finn's here two bags
packed full of film yeah yeah and this
almost like half the quantity of sharks
to Finn's it's not working it's not
making sense and he's upset that I'm
here but who's regulating this there are
more things that are sharks Wow look two
massive bags you just asking a question
first
okay thank you no one checks anything no
one's regulating I think you know no
[ __ ]
this is a huge catch here and the scary
thing is 80% of the Sharks here
I'm not even local shut up they're from
the rest of the world I've seen where
the Sharks have been landed now I want
to go to the frontline of the fin trade
to the fishing grounds where the Sharks
have been caught
you